aussi peut-être on est fait pour la
première fois ce que l'on peut appeler
véritablement la voiture de demain
l'archi les prémonitoire 1971 il y a 50
ans la voiture électrique était déjà
considéré comme un transport d'avenir
pourtant elle a eu du mal à se
développer et surtout à s'imposer chez
les Français est-ce que ça te prête à
changer votre voiture à essence pour une
voiture électrique
voiture électrique ont vu le jour au 19e
siècle les plus connus les voici la
jamais contente créé en 1899 ou encore
neuf électrique conçu par le designer
polar Vincent 1942 à l'époque il s'agit
seulement de prototype
appeler électrique c'est vrai que
l'artiste a construit lui-même dans son
atelier de Montparnasse rayon d'action
250 km est atteint la vitesse de 75 km à
l'heure
d'autres prototypes suivront notamment à
partir des années 70
1973 le prix du baril c'est le premier
choc pétrolier conséquences il faut
trouver et développer des énergies
alternatives par miel l'électricité peu
de bruit pas de pollution c'est la
voiture de l'avenir en 1974 EDF prête
des Renault 4L à la ville de Dijon là
aussi c'est une expérimentation seul le
personnel municipal peut les conduire
Robert Poujade alors ministre de
l'Environnement est présent pour
l'occasion
ce sont des voitures qui vous le savez
une peluche absolument pas il y a aucun
dégagement de de gaz polluants et
d'autre part vous avez pu le constater
ce sont des voiture exceptionnellement
silencieuse mais la voiture électrique
ne s'impose pas elle n'est toujours pas
commercialisé trop lente trop cher à
produire par rapport aux autres
véhicules son autonomie et aussi limité
bref les usagers la boude abominablement
cher et 80 km ensuite vous avez combien
d'heures de recharge une nuit une nuit
de recherche pour 80 km ça fait beaucoup
la voiture électrique se développe
réellement à partir des années 2000 mais
là encore c'est compliqué difficile pour
les Français de remplacer les véhicules
à essence bien moins coûteux à la fin
c'est un véhicule de riche direct qui
peut arriver en deuxième ou troisième
voiture mais les gens modestes ont déjà
des difficultés pour acheter un véhicule
et qu'il achète d'occasion je vois mal
comment il peut m'investir aujourd'hui
on est des choses dans une voiture
électrique aujourd'hui des existe pour
acheter une voiture électrique même si
elle reste minoritaire sur les routes
elle commence petit à petit à s'imposer
un exemple en 2021
783000 voitures électriques ont été
vendu en Europe soit près de deux fois
plus qu'en 2020
[Musique]